let's talk about bodily autonomy okay
this is
really the number one pro-abortion
argument this is the pro-abortion
argument that pro aborts think is
irrefutable they think that they're very
proud of this argument because they
think it's it is the argument that
cannot be refuted that's how good it is
and it's the argument now that upon
which they've based their entire
pro-abortion position many Pro boards
have at this point really basically
conceded or or at least decided to move
beyond the personhood debate
so for a lot of pro-abortion people
they're not gonna argue with you about
windus personhood begin when does life
begin is the fetus a human life is it a
person a lot of proportion people will
say well it doesn't matter
call the fetus whatever you want to call
it life not a life person not a lot not
a person doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what the fetus is all
that matters is my autonomy my right
over my own body
what you'll hear these days is that
personhood begins
whenever the mother decides that is now
the scientific position of of pro aborts
that personhood life begins whenever the
mother wants it to because she has
autonomy and this autonomy gives her the
really supernatural ability to grant or
rescind humanity to and from her child
depending on what she wants so if she
wants the baby to be a human being at 20
weeks it's a human being at 20 weeks if
she wants it to be a human at the moment
of conception it's a human at conception
if she wants it to be a human right
right at the moment of birth and that's
what it's human if she never wants to be
a human then it's never a human this is
the godlike supernatural power that
probe orts we'll say a mother has
this is what the bodily autonomy
position necessitates in assessed states
either that the humanity and personhood
of the child depends on the mother's
wishes because of her autonomy or the
humanity and personhood just don't
matter at all and it just it's an
irrelevant question because the mother
has her body body and she can do what
she wants with
so I'd like to take this
what is considered to be this great
brilliant pro-abortion argument the
pro-abortion argument that nobody could
possibly argue against and
I'd like to prove that it is actually
completely totally utterly ridiculous
now I did this in my book the unholy
trinity came out last year I was I kind
of deconstructed the bodily autonomy
argument I think it's worth 3/8
reiterating because as I said this
really now is the pro-abortion position
this is their entire really this is
their entire position so now I'm going
to explain why bodily autonomy is a bad
argument okay number one the most
obvious problem and the first problem
that most pro lifers will mention is
that it's not your body
your body is not the body at issue here
the issue is the child's body not yours
so your body is a the child's body is B
a and B are not the same they are
distinct separate entities
this I'm afraid is a scientific fact
you're not gonna find any scientist with
more than two brain cells in his head
who will argue that B actually is a and
I can find any scientist who will
actually say that that the child is the
mother's body
because that would be insanity
so not your body child's body your body
not the same
but okay you say fine the child's body
is is not the same as my body
however the child's body is dependent
upon mine and I have the right to
withdraw my support from this dependent
entity I have the right to remove my
body from this other body which has
attached itself to me like some alien
parasite right and this is how I
exercise my autonomy by I should have
the right to say to this
tyrannical dictator in my womb I should
have the right to say to it I am NOT
going to serve you anymore okay I'm not
gonna be your slave I'm not gonna be
your handmaid
and here you'll probably also give me
some variation of the Judith Jarvis
Thomson analogy of a person who you've
heard this analogy before or some
version of it of a person who wakes up
in a hospital attached attached by wires
to some other person some stranger and
the wires are keeping him alive
and a pro abort will claim that this is
what pregnancy is it's like waking up at
a hospital one day and looking over and
seeing there's all these weird wires
coming off of you and they're attached
to some unconscious person over there
and then the nurse comes in and says oh
you know what we're gonna need you to
stay like this for the next nine months
in order to keep that person alive
that's what
that apparently is supposed to be a an
accurate representation of pregnancy
right
and then the person who makes the
analogy analogy will say well what if it
happened to you would you not have the
right to detach yourself from this other
person
yes I would have the right
however you should not have that right
and I'll tell you what
number two because abortion is not the
act of merely detaching yourself from
this other body abortion is not simply
unplugging okay
abortion is is is not
that's not what abortion is abort abort
is not withdrawing from the baby
abortion is rather the active purposeful
direct killing of another human life
you see even if I completely agreed with
the bodily autonomy argument which I
don't but even if I did
I still would oppose abortion
bodily autonomy argument doesn't get you
all the way to abortion
because if the idea is that a woman has
the right to detach herself from her
baby to extricate herself from the
situation to remove herself from this
dependent life form
that would mean yes okay we have to take
the other life form out of her right
it would not mean that we have to kill
it before we take it out
that's what abortion is abortion is
killing the baby directly
somehow this gets lost in the abortion
debate somehow abortion itself gets lost
in the debate about abortion and we talk
about abortion as if it is simply just
unplugging or separating these two
individuals
no abortion is killing one of the
individuals on purpose directly
babies are quote viable at 22 weeks now
I think so and that number is getting
lower and lower
which means that the baby can survive
outside of the womb at 22 weeks now yet
the probe or to make the bodily autonomy
argument they are in almost every case
that I've ever encountered they are not
in favor of abortion restrictions at
viability they the bodily autonomy probe
orts they're in favor of abortion from
conception all the way up to the very
moment before birth
you
if a woman decides to exercise her
autonomy at 22 weeks or 23 or any time
or any time thereafter
well that means okay yes the baby has to
come out one way or another
you
but why must the baby be stabbed with
poison first
why must he be dealin why must he be
ripped out limb from limb why must his
skull be crushed I'm sorry to be graphic
but this is what abortion is and what in
the in the later terms
in abortion the abortionist is saying
okay we got to get this baby out
and so his method of taking the baby out
is to rip it out with forceps one limb
at a time
another way to take a baby out is to
just take the entire baby out whole and
still alive and then to take it away
from the mother bring it up to the NICU
and then and then hope that someone will
come and adopt the child that what
so if we're talking about bodily
autonomy wouldn't bodily autonomy simply
necessitate the delivery of the child
to actively kill the child in the
process is a step a rather large step a
significant step beyond autonomy you've
gone beyond it oh the only place that
autonomy gets you if I were to agree
that you have autonomy which you don't
look at that in a minute but do that
only gets you as far as okay get this
baby out
kill the baby is another step and it's
got nothing to do with autonomy
whatsoever
killing the baby is just pure murder and
that's all it is
that this is also
by the way why the the life of the
mother arguments for abortion are
completely bunk
we're told that sometimes it's necessary
to get an abortion to save a mother's
life
it is never necessary never it is never
ever ever necessary to kill a child in
order to save a mother never I say again
I said never enough it's never anytime
someone says life of the mother please
remind them that has never happened ever
there has never been a life-saving
abortion ever committed ever
now it could be the case sometimes that
something catastrophic aliy you know
some catastrophic thing happens in the
course of a pregnancy and now the baby
has to come out in order to save the
mother's life and maybe even to save the
baby's life that does happen
and so what do you do you take the baby
but the extra step of killing the baby
before you take it out that doesn't do
anything for the mother
that only puts the mother more at risk
that extra step of killing the baby
first is an is an extra step it's a
dangerous extra step the safest thing
would just be to take the baby out
there's no read there's no medical
reason why the baby has to die first
number three
bodily autonomy arguments especially
when argued using the attach to a
stranger by wires analogy these
arguments completely disregard that the
relationship involved here
it's it's no coincidence that when
someone does the whole well what if
you're attached by wires to someone in
the hospital the person you're attached
to in that analogy is always a stranger
have you noticed that always a stranger
but the relationship that we're dealing
with here in pregnancy is that of a
mother and child the child is not a
stranger he's not some alien species
which has attached itself to you that's
your child
to claim autonomy is to claim that your
status as the child's mother has no
significance whatsoever and carries with
it no special responsibilities at all
but we all know that's not true
nobody actually believes that nobody
society couldn't function if we all
actually believe that
do we not require okay require by law
that parents make all sorts of
sacrifices do all sorts of things for
their kids that they're not required to
do for strangers we say to parents you
must feed your child clothe your child
educate your child discipline your child
shelter your child
all of this is very taxing for the
parent it is a claim on the parents
autonomy all of it is it involves the
parents heart mind body soul bank
accounts what the law says to parents of
born children is that yes you must
invest your entire being into this
person your autonomy is gone because you
have a responsibility to this person you
are not autonomous as a parent that's
what the law says and that's what
everybody in society actually believes
now if you decide if you have a child
and you decide you're going to click
neglect your child you're not going to
feed it
you're not going to provide clothes
you're gonna make your child sleep
outside on a doghouse rather than inside
your home or you're just going to
outright abort your child and kill your
truck
you wouldn't be able to go before the
judge and say well how would you like it
if some stranger moved into your house
and demanded food
well I wouldn't like it at all I admit
that if some stranger barged into my
home and said give me food I wouldn't be
a fan of it but that's not a stranger
that's your child you have a
responsibility to him
you have a responsibility to him that
nobody else has you have a special and
unique responsibility to your own
children sorry if you don't like it but
that's just the fact of the matter
so I asked you if we require by law that
parents care for their children provide
for their children see to their
children's every need or else at least
make arrangements for someone else to do
all that what happens at birth
that suddenly creates this Duty and why
does it not exist a second beforehand
all I'm saying is again we all agree
that parents of borin children are not
autonomous and they have all kinds of
responsibilities to their children and
and if they don't want to fulfill those
responsibilities they have to find
someone who will fulfill them and they
certainly can't just kill their child no
matter how stressed out they are and no
matter how draining it is to be a parent
and we say that to the parent because
you're the parent that's your child you
are responsible to it that's what it
means to be to be living in a civilized
society so all I'm saying is logically
we should take that principle and apply
it to the womb as well because it's the
same child
nothing changes it's the same person and
so in your relationship is the same and
therefore the responsibilities should be
the same number four if probe or if
abortion prohibitions are a violation of
bodily autonomy then who is the one
violating the woman's autonomy well it
would have to be the baby
I mean that's who's violating you right
if you're saying I am violated by being
forced to keep this baby in my in my
womb or this fetus well who really is
that is though is the guilty party here
you say that being forced to carry a
baby is a violation of autonomy well
that means that the baby is the one
violating
and those who make abortion illegal in
this equation are merely forcing you to
endure that violation but the vile but
the but the guilty party here is the
baby which I guess is why he gets
capital punishment but wait a second
here's the problem the baby is in the
only place he can be the baby is in the
place that nature has degree decreed he
is in his natural environment he is
following natural order
so a baby in the womb that is a part of
natural order okay someone being
attached to a stranger by wires in the
hospital that is not really a part of
the natural order that is something
extraordinary and beyond nature
but a baby in the womb that's just
nature
it's not a corruption of nature okay so
you can't say well cancer is part of
nature too are you saying I can't get
cancer treated cancer is a corruption of
nature its nature gone wrong a baby in
the womb is just that's nature working
exactly as nature has to work in order
for the species to be propagated so the
baby really is not the one violating you
I guess nature is violating you here
but how can nature violate your rights
when rights themselves if they exist at
all
our natural we call we talk about
natural rights our country is that the
Constitution is founded on the basis of
natural human rights
so if you're claiming that you have a
right to abortion which is which somehow
is in the Constitution right even though
I must be written in invisible ink
because I've never seen it but if it's
in there that that means it's based on
natural rights
rights from nature from the natural
order which is to say from God but for
the sake of this argument if you want to
call it nature of fine
so Nature has decided that all human
beings must be born this way
yet Nature has also decided that it's a
violation of your rights when humans are
born this way
how does it
I don't understand how could you have a
natural right to usurp and destroy this
natural and good and healthy process how
could those both of those things be from
nature
and if you're saying that nature is your
oppressor if you're saying that
pregnancy itself is an oppressive thing
that I should not be subjected to well
nature is at fault and fine the nature
is your oppressor but then don't appeal
to nature that is two natural rights
when fighting against this oppression
oppression
don't appeal to the very thing that is
oppressing you apparently
now if you admit that your right to
abortion is not natural and it's not
from nature but it is just the arbitrary
decree of man and governments
that I would say that the arbitrary
decree is arbitrary and thus should be
overturned and if you believe that
rights do not come from nature and as
we've already said for abortion to work
for the bodily autonomy argument to work
you would you have to admit that these
right this right is not from nature
because pregnancy is from nature so so
where does the right come from well it
comes from the government then I guess
in that case but then you couldn't very
well complain when the government
overturns that right or restricts
abortion can you
Iowa just passed a very restrictive
abortion laws you can't complain about
that if you think that rights come from
government because then that means the
government can change its mind and then
the rights are gone it doesn't make any
sense to say oh the government is
infringing on my rights if the rights
come from government if you say that the
government is infringing on your rights
then you are appealing to some higher
order above the government but we've
already explained that you can't do that
because it's that higher order which has
decided that you should have this baby
and carry it in your womb
number five last point
it really all comes back to this
complete bodily autonomy
does not exist
so I've just spent the last four points
explaining all this for all these
problems with autonomy and everything
what it really comes down to is autonomy
does not exist it's not a real thing it
doesn't exist
you are not autonomous and you never
will be
human beings are not autonomous
creatures we are not these entirely
sovereign independent entities with no
duty or responsibility at all to our
fellow man or our families but that's
what complete autonomy would have to
meet it means you are entirely sovereign
and to yourself and if we talk about an
entirely sovereign autonomous country
what we're saying is this is a country
that can make its own laws do its own
thing and it has no you know it is it
cannot be controlled to an extent by any
other country
and so if you're a completely autonomous
individual it means that you have no
responsibilities at all whatsoever to
anyone
and you would not be able to say well
okay but we all know we have autonomy
but we only have autonomy up until the
point when we harm someone else so if
you're a pro-abortion you cannot make
the argument that well we have the right
to do whatever we want a lot as long as
we're not harming anybody else
abortion is most certainly harming
someone else there's no dispute about
that
so what you're actually proposing here
think about this you're proposing an
autonomy that does allow you to harm
other people you're proposing an
autonomy that allows even for murder
which is you're proposing anarchy okay
you're proposing that we are so
autonomous so sovereign
so free from any social responsibilities
will at all that we could even kill
other people
and we can justify it based on the fact
that this is me doing what I want to do
why did I kill my neighbor because I
wanted to kill my neighbor hey you don't
want to kill neighbors don't kill
neighbors don't like neighbor killing
don't kill neighbors I wanted to kill my
neighbor so I did that's why I did it
I'm autonomous I used my autonomous
sovereign entity of a body to kill my
neighbor
all right that's what autonomy means
so then you have to say okay well this
right to a violent murderous autonomy
only extends to those who are dependent
upon us
well I would say that's a rather
arbitrary designation and you've already
done away with complete autonomy by
making that designation now complete
autonomy is out the window it's gone
but fine in that case well that means
certainly as I've already covered
parents with children of any age up
until 18 can do as they please to their
children they can decline to feed them
clothe them shelter them and they can
even murder them
if the principle is established in the
womb holds which it must for autonomy
and then what about those who are
dependent on the system what about those
who are dependent on me my children are
dependent on me there are people who are
dependent on me as taxpayers what about
welfare recipients well again complete
autonomy would mean that I can certainly
withdraw my money from them anytime I
want because I'm autonomous I have no I
mean if I don't even have responsibility
to my child how could I possibly have
responsibility to this person who I
don't even know
so I should have the right by the by the
logic of atomic to withdraw my money and
and even if I wish to eradicate them
because they are dependent at some level
on me
so if the logic in the womb holds it
means I should be able to kill them
you
so we see that bodily autonomy gives us
the right to do whatever we want to
anyone
partial bodily autonomy gives us the
right to at least murder children up
until the age of 18 plus welfare
recipients and Social Security
recipients so on
now partial partial autonomy may
preclude the mass murder of those on
entitlements but it still very clearly
gives me the abortive authority over any
dependent child of mine at NIH
so what sort of autonomy is the kind of
autonomy where you're forced to provide
for folks on welfare and food stamps and
Social Security and you're forced to
provide for your own kids up until the
age of 18 but you can still murder them
in the womb
what is that I mean that ain't complete
autonomy that's not even anywhere close
to complete autonomy that is partial
partial partial partial autonomy
which is a far cry from complete
autonomy which is what Pro boards claim
we have
and when you get to the point where
you're claiming partial partial partial
partial conditional temporary autonomy
which during this period of time gives
you the right to do whatever you want to
this specific other person up to and
including crushing their skulls and
killing them when we're talking about
that sort of autonomy it becomes clear
that well actually autonomy doesn't
exist
that's not autonomy at all I don't know
what that is I do know what it is it's
murder
that's all that is that's not a ton of
me it's got nothing to do with autonomy
the logic of autonomy is is is not
involved here whatsoever
it starts to seem that you're just using
autonomy as an excuse
funny how that works
you
so that's the five step process for
deconstructing the autonomy argument and
that's it so now everyone can stop using
if only I if only it really worked that
way all right
I'll leave it there thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening and
Godspeed